While being famous may seem like a blessing,
it has a lot of drawbacks.
Constant public attention and media scrutiny
is not an easy thing to deal with, and it
makes it almost impossible to have a normal
life.
Even when they’re not working, actors are
still on the clock.
With their careers constantly in flux, the
slightest action could change everything.
The movies can be a surprisingly fickle business.
In an industry where things are so fluid,
a performer can go from zero to hero overnight,
but unfortunately, the opposite is also true.
So wether it’s because of their careers,
sketchy personal lives, or simply falling
victim to the Hollywood machine, here are
10 Actors Who Have Aged In Shocking Ways.
Macaulay Culkin
One of the cutest kids to ever appear on screen,
Macaulay Culkin’s most iconic work is enjoyable
to this day.
When the holidays come around, people order
themselves an extra cheese pizza, make an
ice cream sundae, and turn on 1990’s Home
Alone.
Watching Kevin McCallister defend his homestead
against two idiot burglars is a timeless experience.
One made even better by 9 year-old Culkin’s
performance.
After the movie’s success, his star began
to rise.
And quickly the actor was making millions
of dollars per movie.
Dollars which were handled by his parents.
Familial turmoil proved overwhelming, and
the young performer ended up leaving the business
until things were sorted out.
After a legal battle where both parents felt
entitled to their child’s money, Culkin
separated himself (and his money) completely.
He’s since returned to acting, and plays
in a band called The Pizza Underground.
Wesley Snipes
Wesley Snipes has a bad attitude toward authority,
and for years that’s part of what’s made
him successful.
When he shows up on screen, odds are, he’s
there to kick multiple asses.
In fact, he’s so good at kicking asses that
he was chosen to play the big-screen adaptation
of Blade, a character who only exists to kick
asses.
But, fans did experience an interruption in
an otherwise consistent stream of ass kicking.
When the actor’s distain for authority landed
him in some trouble with the IRS.
He spent three years in jail for tax evasion.
Ouch.
Mel Gibson
If you took a time machine back to the early
nineties, you couldn’t find a more in-demand
actor than Mel Gibson.
If you were to tell someone that in the future
the actor would be abandoned by his agency,
they’d look at you like you were nuts..
but you wouldn’t be wrong.
He was a Hollywood powerhouse making moves
on screen and off, and has the Academy Awards
from Braveheart to prove it.
But rumors about Gibson began to spread years
later, and after a few voicemails found their
way to the internet, a lot of those rumors
were proven.
Lots of activist groups had some choice words
for the actor.
He offended a lot of people in a short timeframe.
And earned him a reputation as a racist, a
misogynist, or all of the above.
Shia LaBeouf
Shia LaBeouf was the best part of Even Stevens,
a show that ran for three seasons on the Disney
channel in the early 2000’s.
And while the network continues to pump out
superstars, it’s also a commonality in many
stories of wholesome young performers gone
wild.
But that wouldn’t happen to Shia, right?
Wrong.
The actor enjoyed massive success after working
hard in the years after Louis Stevens, and
became the face of Michael Bay’s Transformers
franchise reboot.
But beginning with a DUI arrest in 2008, his
public persona started to change in a big
way.
The actor was called out for plagiarizing
work by writer Daniel Clowes, and then responded
to the backlash with a plagiarized apology.
He’s still acting, just mostly in memes.
Winona Ryder
Winona Ryder has been working since the late
eighties, and has been part of legendary movies
in the process.
From Beetlejuice and Edward Scissorhands,
to Reality Bites and Girl, Interrupted, the
actress proved that she could hop between
genres with ease.
Longevity is not something a lot of actresses
experience, and Hollywood is often accused
of being harder on women than they are on
men.
So while she may have been untouchable as
a performer, as a human she was fair game.
And when she was busted for shoplifting in
2001, the media ran with it.
Recently the actress acknowledged the incident
and asserted that the whole thing was blown
out of proportion.
She never strayed too far from the big screen
though, and recently teamed up with Netflix
for the enormously successful Stranger Things.
Chevy Chase
As one of the original cast members of Saturday
Night Live, Chevy Chase has got some serious
bragging rights.
And he’s one of the O.G’s of comedy.
So when Dan Harmon was looking for an older
actor to play a community college curmudgeon
for his T.V. show, Chase was the right choice.
The show had it’s highs and lows but gained
a loyal fanbase thanks to it’s quirky style.
Everyone was having a blast on set, except
for Chase.
He and Harmon clashed when it came to defining
what is (and isn’t) funny.
After the actor left an angry voicemail for
Harmon, it was leaked onto the internet.
That, coupled with reports of him using racial
epithets on set, ultimately led to his character
Pierce being scaled way back in the series.
And the stigma has followed him since.
Amanda Bynes,
Since the beginning of her career, Amanda
Bynes has proven that girls can be hilarious.
Starting out on Niclekodeon’s sketch comedy
show All That, she climbed the ladder all
the way to feature films.
And even though the actress was unbelievable
in She’s The Man, the majority of audiences
will recognize her from the 2007 film adaptation
of Hairspray.
The starlet retired from acting in 2010, but
stayed in the public eye because of some erratic
behavior, and a string of tweets.
In 2012, Bynes was arrested numerous times
and charged with DUIs among other things.
Fans watched as the actress took her rants
to Twitter, prompting a few professionals
to intervene.
She’s now enrolled in fashion school, and
recently spoken about how she received the
help she needed.
Lindsay Lohan
If you were around in the nineties, you probably
remember the 1998 remake of The Parent Trap.
Where two identically adorable kids conspire
to reunite their parents.
And that’s when the world met little Lindsay
Lohan, who played both of the movie’s freckled
twins.
Audiences were surprised that such a young
kid could do double duty.
Especially when most singular kids roles actually
require twins.
When strict on-set schooling guidelines clash
with the pace of filmmaking, frankly it’s
easier to swap them out.
Lohan was quick to make her newfound Hollywood
cred work for her, and landed a role that
catapulted her to stardom in 2004’s Mean
Girls.
But as the years went on, her talent was overshadowed
by some personal drama.
And while she’s continued to do some acting
work since, her earlier success has never
been replicated.
Johnny Depp
Viewers were introduced to Johnny Depp in
a little show called 21 Jump Street.
And after he asked to be fired, the actor
took a hard left into a career that would
take him as far away from his wholesome image
as possible.
The actor showed off his range in the years
to come, and that earned him points will all
kinds of moviegoers.
From Edward Scissorhands to Benny & Joon to
Donnie Brasco, Depp’s work was all over
the map.
And then in 2003, Pirates of the Caribbean
happened.
Beginning with Captain Jack Sparrow, Depp’s
opponents argue all his roles began to bleed
into one: a quirky guy with a quirkier hat.
And that the only thing on display now is
his wasted talent.
Gwyneth Paltrow
You wouldn’t know it by her reputation today,
but Gwyneth Paltrow used to be one of America’s
sweethearts.
The actress has quite the range, too.
She was adorable as young Wendy in 1991’s
Hook.
She even got to be the head in the box at
the end of Se7en.
(“WHATS IN THE BOXXXXX”) But since her
Oscar win for 1998’s Shakespeare In Love,
she slowly began to lose favor with audiences.
The actress is a vocal supporter of a very
specific type of diet and lifestyle.
Which, for a lot of people, is far too pricey
to commit to.
She also made moms everywhere shake with rage
when she insisted that parenting was easy
for them, but hard for her, and never acknowledged
the disparity in that statement.
It seems like the more public her personal
life gets, the less audiences like her.
What do you think of our list?
Did we miss any actors whose careers aged
horribly?
Tell us about them in the comments, and subscribe
to our YouTube channel for more videos like
this one.